57 años después de haber caminado por la
alfombra roja del festival de cannes con
la película los paraguas de cherburgo y
haberse llevado la palma de oro regresó
esta noche aquí el festival de cannes la
actriz francesa catherine deneuve que
participa fuera de competencia con la
película de sound y done recordemos que
ella hace un año y medio túnez el
cerebro vascular y además estuvo en el
año 2019 en el festival de cannes
entregando la palma de oro al director
coreano bong o por su película parásito
también esta noche en walf hombre arroja
para el actor y realizador
estadounidense jump en que participa de
la competencia oficial con su película
el día de la bandera
filmada junto a sus dos hijos la última
experiencia de samper en el festival de
cannes fue en el año 2016 cuando su
película de las spice junto a javier
bardem fue muy mal recibida por la
crítica